good morning John it is Tuesday June
23rd it is actually not Tuesday June
23rd Monday June 22nd but I have to make
this video now because our parents are
coming into town tomorrow and they are
probably gonna want me to hang out with
them instead of hanging out with YouTube
because they're my parents and they gave
birth to me and stuff I guess only mom
gave birth to me
dad this sort of stood there
every time one of our videos can pick up
on the 4pt YouTube there's a lot of
confusion and there's also a lot of
meanness so I wanted to make this video
for two reasons one because I wanted to
kind of help people understand what it
is you and I do here apparently I do
this and two I wanted to help release
the crushing weight on my soul that is
the haters of YouTube by responding to
their comments so I'm going to respond
to some header comment I'm should not so
hater comments from our most recent
video about the youtube video volunteers
program click on my face and so that you
know whether I'm being a commenter or
being me I'm going to be wearing this
duck head on my face when I'm a
commenter this piece got stuck in my
mouth if you think the world sucks then
why are you living on it well one I
didn't really know that I had a choice
but additionally I think one of the
great things about being on the world is
that you get to make it suck less the
world does suck that's why we should
destroy it I'm gonna have to disagree
with you on that point and I don't have
any complicated philosophical reasons
why how come John never blinks
how come this duck never blinks actually
the real reason that John never blinks
is because a frank a pioneering video
blogger never blinked and everything we
do is stolen directly from say Frank you
should go watched a Frank it's better
than us Hank is a MILF none of any of
the letters in that acronym could
possibly apply to me are you guys in the
same room um no John and I actually
started this project because we live
across the country from each other and
we wanted to talk to each other more I
realize that our bookshelves look
remarkably similar but if you look on
Jon's bookshelf you see that there's
laying books like the Norton Anthology
for English literature and if you look
on my bookshelf there's totally awesome
books
Haarlem w said don't forget to be
awesome that has to be my new favorite
saying and then mister big balls said
whatever this geek conversation is lame
and then Grandpa Joe said um thank you
for your input mister big balls and I
don't have anything to say about that
conversation I just thought it was great
don't forget to be awesome is one of the
things that we say around here we also
just say dftba because it's easier to
say then don't forget to be awesome but
the basic idea is you know sometimes we
forget to be awesome so we should remind
ourselves not to as often as possible
not buried gayish but not gay you could
totally see my wedding ring throughout
that entire video you just not paying
attention dude wasted three minutes in
seven seconds of my life well I guess I
guess I just have to say I
appreciate you watching the whole video
you probably felt like it was gonna
waste your life like 13 seconds in but
then you watch the whole video you stuck
it out man you'll never get that time
back I'm not giving it back to you I'm
no fall of autumn distro I do not return
your three minutes if you don't know
what I'm talking about
click here dirty' said what's your
ringtone older vlog brother and then Jon
respond to this one too
it's the party blower solo from an
amazing song that my brother did you can
watch the video here now the last part
wasn't actually in the comment but you
can yes how did you know that I was the
older loved brother and then dirty
replied because the fatter ones are
usually older no offense though thanks
for calling and fat and then saying no
offense like that makes it all better
I'm not say note Hank I noticed that
what are your incisors just bigger than
the other is there anything that you
could do about that because it's really
bothering me the fact that my incisor is
slightly too art probably bothers you
less than dental surgery would bother me
just II guess what is a nerdfighter and
how could I be one nerdfighters of
people who fight for awesome and are
excited about learning things and
discovering things and understanding
other people as they wish to be
understood complexly and with that and
if you want to be a nerdfighter then you
probably are so you should stop worrying
about it
well that is all i've got for you people
thank you all so very much for
considering participation in the video
volunteers program i hope to see you all
creating video volunteer videos soon
john you won't even see me tomorrow but
my video is going to be kind of cool so
i hope that you enjoy it